oh quel jour si c'était moi
j'aurais tué cet homme si tu ne tenais pas
tête au patron le vin va juste être
emporté
tu es d'accord là facture femme a fait des spaghettis
pour le dîner semblait dommage de vomir
problème de jeu je  J'ai entendu dire que tu ne dis pas
J'ai entendu de la drogue J'ai entendu dire qu'il a couché avec
un tiers pour l'amour de Pete Bob ne répands pas de
rumeurs non jouait Je suis content que mon
mari soit mort Je vais chanter à ses
funérailles c'est un peu étrange hein  pense que
cela pourrait être comme un
truc de crime organisé donne moi l'argent je suis désolé de la
projection je n'ai rien fait je ne l'ai pas fait